the new year comes several new laws
going into effect and one of them has to
do with gun control and keeping illegal
guns off the street hector mejia joins
us live now from the newsroom hector the
new law bans firearms without serial
numbers tell us more about that that's
correct sherry it is now illegal for a
person to sell and possess firearms that
do not have serial numbers we're talking
about untraceable guns known as ghost
guns this started as assembly bill 286
which was passed last year by state
lawmakers and signed by governor steve
sisilak back in june it targets guns
that can often be made at home from kits
or 3d printers however it has exceptions
it excludes licensed manufacturers guns
made before 1969 antiques or guns that
are permanently inoperable the first
offense is considered a gross
misdemeanor
which is punishable by up to a year in
jail and a potential two thousand dollar
fine after that it becomes a category d
felony if convicted that means time in
state prison between one and four years
that sentence also carries a potential
fine of up to five thousand dollars
supporters of the bill say it's aimed at
preventing gun violence during hearings
we also they also mentioned recent local
shootings particularly the one october
massacre on the las vegas strip and we
also heard from from others the nevada
firearms coalition opposed the bill from
the beginning saying making your own gun
is a hobby for many people reporting
live in our newsroom hector mejia live
local now